- I want to ask about Black Panther 2.
First of all, just amazing films.
But will the queen get to
fight in this next one?
Because I want you to.
- Really?
- Come on!
- Oh, she's gon'...
She's gon' show her strength.
- (indistinct)
Yeah!
- She's gon' s...
Oh.
- I saw--
- [Angela] Aw, with Chadwick.
(audience applauding)
- It's literally...
That is one of the films
that's seen most in my house.
My five year old son is obsessed.
- Really?
- Is obsessed.
Every Halloween, he wants
to be Black Panther.
- Aw, I love that.
- Yep, every Halloween.
It's so cool just how...
And it's cool, like...
I know it's a superhero thing
but it's a cool that...
Like, to be able to be a character
in these movies that
these kids will grow up
just loving and you
get to be a part of it,
it's such a cultural thing that's so...
Not many people get be a part of.
- [Angela] Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- From queens and kings, queens.
You see that representation.
- But also, like...
Representation and also good messaging.
It's one step further, I think,
than when we were kids.
- Absolutely.
- I think it's really--
- I really give a lot up
to our director and our
writer, Ryan Coogler.
I mean, he's such a tremendous talent
and everyone that he brings on that set,
everyone in front of...
In front of the camera
and behind the camera,
so impressive,
and giving 1,000% of their gifts!
And we all have gifts.
So it's a beautiful place.
- Oh, the cast is insane!
Yeah.
It's like you see the cast
and you're like, "Okay, play."